two quick questions that's it faraz says
in the context of embody cognition and
by the way froz is someone
who graduated from u of t
right around here in neuroscience and i
forgot the other one so he's gonna
comment in the comment section about
what i forgot
in the context of embody cognition what
is the relationship between perception
and mathematics
and furthermore if the external world
perceives
our actions can we extrapolate from that
assertion
the idea that our actions matter to the
world as well
so that that question you you sort of
hinted at before when you were
when you were the duality between
internal external
exactly yeah that that sort of um
perfect
symmetry um which i thought was you know
that that was insightful and i think
um that insight sort of speaks to the
second half half of this question here
um so you know it is certainly the case
that
when you simulate um agents
con specifics in a particular
environment or eco niche
um and you just integrate these
simul simulation of physics engines
um using um
the free energy principle you get the um
the kind of um learning
that um you would normally expect to see
in the agents about the environment but
that is exactly mirrored by the
environment learning about
the denizens that you know it plays host
to so i'm sure you know this but you
know
my favorite example from colleagues who
really you know
push these arguments as far as they they
can go at the present time
my favorite um their favorite and my
favorite example
is a notion of a desire path or an
elephant path
which is the the phenomenon
that say i'm going to get my coffee from
the cafe
on the other side of a green or a park
and i can either walk around on the
pavement
or i can take a shortcut across the
grass
and if i so do um i will
eventually me and all my con specifics
will eventually
wear a um a dusty trail
of grassless signs and queues
from my office directly to the cafe
so from the point of view of the
environment this is basically the
environment learning about the behavior
of the kinds
of agents that you know that occupies
that um that
that environment so the environment is
learning about the behavior
by being eroded by being changed so it's
literally just
remembering in its structure in its
sub-personal
structure it is learning about the uh
the con specifics
that are good for occupying that
environment
the con specifics that are occupying
that environment what are the con
specifics
oh a con a con specific um you and i are
con specifics because we're from the
same species
so is it sorry it's just a way of
describing an ensemble of or a
collection
of phenotypes agents that have
the you know come from the same species
and the environment can learn this is
the kind of phenotype
that that operates well in my
environment
whilst at the same time the phenotypes
are trying to change to operate better
in this environment so there's
a there's a you know circular causality
your while while the while the the
the phenotypes or the con specifics are
trying to adapt to the environment
the environment is also adapting to
those con specifics so it's a dance
um that in fact can get quite high order
in the sense now that that you and i
will now see the path and realize oh
that must
this path leads to to somewhere that it
must be nice for things like me to go
so i can just infer seeing a desire path
that it will lead to something i desire
because i know
that everybody else who has used that
are con specifics
they like the same kinds of things they
have the same attracting sets
so now the environment has learned about
the the phenotypes and has
memorized it in its structure and now
the phenotypes are now using that to
infer the kinds of things that i should
do
so now you get something like just using
the environment
to cooperate and to signal and to change
um and to provide information for other
things other creatures like me
and you can take that right through to
the emergence of roads
of traffic lights of language so you
move these arguments that's interesting
so language is that part of the
environment or is it part of poppa's
third world or
is it you know is it part of your brain
i yeah i don't think you can tie it down
like that because of this circular
causarty
um that you you hinted at more than
hinted at
when you're when you recognize that a
markov blanket you know it's quite
arbitrary what is internal external just
depends upon
which point of view you're taking so
there's a really interesting question
which you can take in many many
different directions
you know i i i'm personally not
um not taking it in those directions
because i got distracted by other things
but i have lots of young colleagues
around the world who are really trying
to
try to understand this in relationship
to evolutionary psychology
evo devo uh the relationship to niche
construction
and the relationship to what andy clark
would have
promoted which is the designed
environment so one of the
one of the sort of um you know key
parts of the triple uh you know the four
e's
you know so yes it is embodied but
there's also
um you know an extension it's situated
um so the environment not just the
physical environment
outside my body but my body as
environment as well starts to become
you know an important part of this
reciprocal loop and the sort of
joint free energy minimizing mechanics
that rests upon a reciprocal uh exchange
between
you know one side of a mark of blanket
and the other side of the markov blanket
uh i'll just close with with the first
part of the question which is
does that mean the environment perceives
i i would say possibly not um
it certainly would be the case
mathematically speaking that the
environment is
learning but we generally reserve the
notion of perception to refer to
to perceptual inference or inference
about
states of the world as opposed to
the parameters of a generative model
which
are more attributes of contingencies
laws
and the like so that we we infer
that the world is in this state or that
state at this point in time
but we learn the contingencies and the
lawful mappings and likelihoods
and the transition probabilities um that
underwrite
the changes and transitions in the state
the other flux of states in the world
so um it it's it's probably the case
that the environment
um the physical environment not the body
environment but so you know things like
roads and paths and buildings
trees um they
they learn that they probably don't
infer and perceive in the sense of
having qualitative experience of qualia
but they do learn um you know they do
update their parameters in a way
to model what's on the other side of
their markov blanket which is you and me
thank you sir you've given you've been
far too generous with your time and i
appreciate it
immensely i think this conversation will
be fruitful for
quite a few people especially more on
the philosophical end there's not many
most of the interviews with you are more
technical so i'm glad that we got a bit
philosophical even though i love
some of the technical questions i have
maybe 30
30 more that i didn't get to but we'll
save that for the next time